The new i-limb Ultra revolution from touch
bionics is the first upper limb prosthesis
that can be controlled with an App.
And students in India created "SHE", or, Society
Harnessing Equipment, lingerie that delivers
82 electric shocks and contacts the local
police in order to ward off attackers.
Vsauce! Kevin here, this is Mind Blow.
After four years, Micromagic systems is finally
ready to reveal "Mantis," the biggest all-terrain
operational hexapod in the world that walks
on six ground-sensing hydraulic legs. The
British robotics firm says the two-ton hexapod
has the ability to manipulate objects, such
as this trailer, automatically level while
riding, and load easily by folding itself
onto a truck bed.
The BIQ house is powered by algae. Created
by design firms Splitterwerk, Arup, and SSC
when used as a "bio-skin" during summer the,
algal growth speeds up providing a cooling
effect for the residents while transferring
that extra heat to hot water systems. Algae
is also harvested and sent to the technical
room where it is fed into a bio mass fuel
converter which provides the remainder of
the building's energy needs - making it self-sufficient.
A new study creates the illusion of having
a phantom limb in non amputee people. Neuroscientists
at Karolinska Institutet in Sweden set up the
experiment by having the participants right
arm hidden, and then they touch that arm with a
brush and imitate the same movements with
another brush in mid air within full view
of the participant. They discovered that within
a minute most participants transferred the
sensation of touch to the area of empty space
where they only see the brush move and thereby experience
a phantom limb. In order to prove the experiment
worked, the scientists would make a stabbing
motions towards the phantom limb and measure
the participants sweat response to the threat
which was increased during the illusion.
And they hope it leads to insight into future
research on phantom pain in amputees. World record 30 skiers holding hands and doing a flip...
New fossil dinosaur embryos suggest that baby
dinosaurs grew at record rates, and also had
the ability to flex their muscles in preparation
for the outside world. The bones had blood
vessels which meant that the tissues were burning
oxygen and growing rapidly, and the structure
of the bones gives researchers reason to believe
the embryos were flexing their legs to strengthen
their muscles.
Wolrd Record 30 skiers holding hands and doing
a flip. Yay.
Fujitsu Laboratories created a touchscreen
interface that connects the real world with
the virtual. It can accurately detects the
user's fingertips creating an interactive touchscreen
for the real world. This allows you to manipulate
paper using a webcam and a commercial projector.
With this ability information can be imported
as data from any document by just using your
fingers to select it. And they're aiming to develop
a commercial version of this by 2014.
Students at Virginia Tech College of Engineering
made a life-like autonomous robotic jelly
fish the size and weight of a grown man. At
5 foot 7 inches and 170 pounds, it's being
developed for the US navy and the goal is
to have the robotic jellyfish in waters around
the world, with the ability to leave it in
the ocean for weeks or even months. Eventually
they may have the ability to clean oil spills,
monitor the environment, or conduct surveillance.
After 4 years Micromagic Systems is finally
ready to reveal MANTIS - the biggest all-terrain
operational hexapod in the world that walks
on six ground sensing hydraulic legs. The
British robotics firm says the 2-tonne hexapod
has the ability to manipulate objects such
as this trailer, automatically level while
riding, and load easily by folding itself
onto a truck bed.
The Cave Automatic Virtual Environment is
a fully immersive six-sided room that projects
3-D environments on its walls. It was created
by the team at UW-Madison and gives users
the ability to move virtual objects using
muscle activity, a projector, and virtual
reality glasses. This allows users to exert
forces against things that are created in
front of them. The hope is that this will
have rehabilitation applications for those
suffering from injuries, strokes, or certain
disabilities.
Finally Festo created BionicOpter - a robotic
dragonfly that has mastered the complex flight
characteristics of its real life counterpart.
I'm going to leave you with a biped robot
that stabilizes its balance if you push it
- and as always thanks for watching...